first of all did you have any idea that
you were actually auditioning to be
Golden Globes hosts when you presented
at the Emmys yes I would actually
separate it but the Emmys is not an
audition for the close Emmys is a
fantastic show in and of itself and we
were there for that and you know it just
so happened that people could see our
chemistry which is terrible I was hoping
when we walked out there that we would
get this gig but I'm kind of like I'm
like climby always trying to leverage
into the next thing but I'm kind of
thirsty AF when did you get the call
that this was going to happen and what
was your reaction you got the call we
got and then we got then we chatted
because I couldn't really believe that
it was real obviously it's clearly real
for Andy because he's hosted many an
awards show and many and it was a real
shock for me I actually thought it was a
joke but then when we spoke I just
thought it's fantastic
terrifying opportunity yeah it's a long
time of live television guys not I'm not
trying to scare you but what can we
expect on Sunday what are we pulling out
of the Hat you have some background in
this and you've got a fresh look out
look
this sound will be going on throughout
the entire shift forklift action during
the show this is how they're gonna play
people off if their speeches go too long
this year they're just gonna start
breaking down the set numbers cameo
surprises you know the Globes is not
notorious for any pre tapes or big
musical numbers it's kind of the joy and
also the limitation of the space it's a
smaller room it's a smaller stage and I
think because of that it's great for
comedy but maybe not necessarily for big
showy numbers just heard that Lady Gaga
and Bradley Cooper are presenting but
that kind of lends itself to like a
quartet guys like a singing like duet
quartet Lady Gaga and Bradley oh I don't
sing I mean I don't
sing you sing well neither does Bradley
Cooper so you're in good company
everyone loves it
citing is that though I would say Barry
were you not expecting them to present
like one of the biggest movies of the
year it's a big deal for us because it
just was announced can we met we've got
news on Entertainment Tonight okay yes I
can't wait to hear their banter quick I
have a speed round for you guys here we
go
ready okay celebrity that should be
worried in the monologue celebrity most
likely to find at the champagne station
[Music]
celebrity who's most likely to make us
cry with our acceptance speech Sandra oh
hey do you want to avoid backstage